prey takes place in 1719 just four years
after the date on the pistol in Predator
2 a flint lock pistol does take center
stage in the third Act of the film one
of the injured fur Trappers gives it to
Naru in exchange for her help tending to
his wounds at the end of the film after
Naru slays the Predator she returns to
her Village and tosses them the pistol
upon careful examination we see that the
pistol is inscribed with the name Rafael
adolini and the year 1715 this is the
same inscription on the pistol from
Predator 2 ultimately tying this film to
the greater Predator Universe it's quite
possibly the film's coolest Easter egg